[Music]
in this kentucky community resilience
and faith run deep
sunday worship is at 11am every week and
it was on this day too for a
congregation who survived in a church
that's still standing
but beyond the first baptist church
mayfield is devastated
businesses
homes
lives destroyed
on every corner in the heart of this
town they are picking up what's left
the tornado cut a path right through the
center whipping up everything
on the corner of sixth and north street
it is all too much for elise ray
and i've been through the town a couple
times and saw everything but it's it's
just
upsetting you know to know that that's
the town that you grew up in and
everything you know his memories is all
gone
the building is what's left of her local
law office and the owner is david
hargrove looks like you're still at your
desk trying to clear up
and you still got a smile on your face
yeah well you know what's resilience
yeah you smile or you cry and
you don't have much time for tears you
know i've had them but uh
just you know we gotta
you know either what's that old movie
singing either get busy living or get
busy dying and so you know we're
we're just uh
trying to clean up as best we can and
get going you know we're not the only
ones obviously this devastation has
you know kind of
never been seen before around here
even the buildings which are still
standing here have lost their roofs the
tower of the historic courthouse was
toppled next to it father and daughter
jim and sarah
well i've lived here my entire life and
seeing everything just destroyed just
kind of hurts honestly i think it'll
come back and come back bigger and
better than ever
it really is an overwhelming experience
here block after block such
extraordinary destruction it will take
them a very long time to recover from
this
imagine being in the middle of all this
as the tornado passed through the town's
firefighters were they stayed in a
station which was hit hard
the building was shaking the lights were
going off there was debris flying
everywhere have you ever experienced
anything like that before never in my
life
on the edge of the town beyond the
roadblock the cost of it all in lives
the candle factory where for two days
and two nights now they have been
searching for survivors more than a
hundred people were working the night
shift here on friday hour by hour good
news seems less probable
[Music]
at the church they are carried by faith
but they will need more than that here
the american president has pledged help
and support it's not here yet though
this is very much a community struggle
now an update that we have got from the
candle factory which really is the the
desperate focus uh here uh in this
particular town they say now that uh
eight people are confirmed to have died
at the factory nine more remain
unaccounted for so
i suppose it is it's positive that the
numbers at the factory the numbers to
have died is not as high as they had
once feared over the course of the
weekend they managed to account for
those
who were missing and yet nine of them
are still missing they still seem to be
holding out some hope that they may be
able to find some people alive under
that rubble the secretary for the
interior
is here and will be giving a news
conference at some point this afternoon
so there is federal help from the
federal government up in washington
washington dc it's coming slowly but i
have to say we've been struck in the
heart of the town at the fact as i said
it is the community uh digging through
the rubble we haven't seen the hi-vis
officials moving around the town it
seems to be coming but it's coming very
slowly for a town that dearly needs help
very fast